he's holding up a plastic bag next to a
chick in a nest okay and saying and
saying
adult birds are feeding plastic to their
chicks there's no pic i've i've searched
the internet thoroughly he's actually
removed one sequence that sequence where
he's holding up the plastic bag it no
longer is available on the internet i
don't know interesting yeah it why did
you say it the first time if about a
year ago if sir before i wrote my book i
i think he's on to me
uh
and
he he's he's an absolute liar in many
many cases and i've made three of them
in the book
one of them is that albatross adults are
feeding plastic to their young
mistaking it for food greenpeace says
the same thing the smithsonian institute
in the united states is saying the same
thing they are pushing this lie
that albatross can't tell plastic from
food
sir david attenborough never mentions
the word gizzard anywhere
he wrote the bloody secret life of
bird's book
he
did a 10 part series on bbc on birds
right
and he doesn't know that birds all have
gizzards that need to have solid objects
in them to grind their food because they
have no teeth and therefore
have two stomachs all birds every bird
in the world that's why all land birds
take pebbles into their stomach and when
their chicks are in the nest and can't
go and get pebbles for themselves they
put pebbles in their chick so if you
have a more convenient pebble that is
made of plastic
and it's able to do the same job then no
the land birds do not feed bits of
plastic to their chicks as far as i know
because there's plenty of pebbles but
out in the ocean where birds are actual
marine animals that
nest on rocky islands barren rocky
islands where all there is is a bit of
grass right there's no pebbles there
either yeah so traditionally their
favorite well naturally they feed their
chick squid little squid
in those squid is a beak
that beak is retained in the gizzard
as part of the digestive aids
right it's like a ball mill in mining
where they put steel balls into a mill
to grind the ore it's exactly the same
concept in many ways but in the in the
gizzard it's a muscular motion where
they go like this with their gizzard and
grind the food with these solid objects
in there to help with it
and so the other thing they'll take is
pumice
which is volcanic lava from undersea
volcanoes and because it's spongy it
floats it's got air in it or gases in it
so it floats so little bits of
pumice will come to the surface
sometimes in huge layers when an
undersea volcano goes off but they're
not it's not always there so they have
to resort them to hard bits of wood and
nuts that have dropped off a plant in a
river or by the seashore and come out in
the ocean so it
they have to work really hard to find
enough digestive aids that are suitable
in size and and hardness
it's not easy for them and when plastic
started showing up in the ocean 60 years
ago
they started choosing pieces of the
right size not plastic bags not
cigarette lighters not spools of yarn
that's all staged they don't feed them
those kind of things and they're
actually they're not feeding the plastic
bits they're giving it to them to ingest
so they can put it in their gizzard
that's where it goes they know how to
decide which goes in which stomach so
the story that i read
had this lady explaining about the
situation and that the parents she'd
used the word feed she'd parents had
come back and given the chicks these
plastic pebbles and i can't remember the
word that they used uh to describe what
happens
as they're just about to fly the nest
some bird wood
the bowlers
maybe that they cough up most of the
hard objects in there
because the reason they have so much in
their gizzard is because they will
digest their food even faster then and
the parents won't have to feed them for
the rest of their lives
right so they want them out of the nest
as soon as possible so they put a lot of
plastic which weighs a lot plastic and
but plastic is never a majority of
what's in
a young bird's gizzard never like it's
shown in those stage photos it's like
all plastic what this lady said was just
as they were about to leave i saw them
eject the the the plastic back up and
throw it back up just because they were
about to leave the nest and yes not just
the plastic not just the plastic but all
the other items they have in there to do
the same job yeah and it's all plastic
is always a minority of it and she's got
all these plastic bags and big plastic
plastic cloths and things that's all
staged yeah well that's not going in but
it's not going to fit in a small bird is
it no it well they're not they're
actually quite big because albatrosses
are big but it's not gonna it's not
gonna work
they only if you see the photo in my
book the only photo i know of of a adult
albatross
giving plastic to its chick you can see
it in its beak going into the chick's
mouth and it's all nice little pieces of
colored plastic
that are just the right shape and size
it's not plastic bags it's not
cigarette lighters like they show in the
staged pictures but when you read that
when you read that article what you see
is if you didn't know that the birds
needed the plastic to break up food in
the stomach if you didn't know that that
was something that aids them with that
digestion and that it is common for them
to throw up the plastic plus presumably
all of the other stuff that's been in
there helping them to break up their
food you would read that article and it
is it is accurate what she says is
correct but the things that have been
purposefully omitted
and the understanding about why some of
the inclusions have been put in there
and why biologically that might still be
natural
that creates a situation and that was
the moment i was reading it and i
thought
this really is
this really is quite sinister it does
feel like it's quite a
manipulative
way
to tell people what has happened but
frame it in such a manner that makes us
again
hate our own existence
you could say evil
as a synonym of sinister
and i believe it is because sir david
attenborough also lied about the
walruses committing suicide due to a
lack of ice
that's the final chapter in my book they
committed suicide was this a harry carry
thing
yes they jumped off a cliff to their
death in order
to avoid an attack by 20 polar bears oh
he didn't mention that part
and that is well documented there are
photographs of the bears the people who
live in a nearby town know that the
reason the walruses leapt off a cliff
was because they were being
about to be attacked and eaten by polar
bears what was the proposed reason
not enough ice as if you can put those
two things together it's sort of like
polar bears are inbreeding because there
isn't enough ice as if those two things
are connected somehow right and he made
it seem as though it was connected that
there was because he said the reason the
polar bears have come on the land
and got to a place
where they could jump off
they did
because there was no ice for them in the
sea below which is always the case on
the north shore of russia the ice
recedes in the summer
and funny enough he says that the he
says the ice is their home no the sea is
their home
that's where the walrus lives and fishes
they don't fish actually
they dig clams
on the bottom
and when the ice recedes away from the
coast and they are coming out of the
water to haul out they come on the land
there's a reason why it is an officially
designated walrus sanctuary this piece
of land and he implies that it's
unnatural that they are coming on the
land because there's not enough ice for
them to get onto
when in fact they cannot exist they are
a coastal species they cannot exist deep
sea so if the ice recedes to where it's
600 feet deep or a thousand feet deep
it's no good to them
because
they are bottom feeders and as i say in
my book they are bottom feeders much
like sir david attenborough and his tv
crew on the planet earth or whatever our
planet right there they too are bottom
feeders in this case
and they are lying because the reason
the walruses
left to their death
fell to their death
they didn't walruses can't actually leap
but they plummeted to their death
because a pack of polar bears was going
to eat them
and instead the polar bears just walked
down to where all the dead walruses were
and ate them while they're dead and i'm
sure the walruses would rather be eaten
while they were dead than while they
were alive
so that's the deal there and he is
bald-faced lying to the whole world
about this and he continues to do it he
had people in davos in tears
recently telling this story even though
he now knows that i have busted him and
so has susan crockford the polar bear
expert who's also an expert in all
arctic animals has busted him publicly
and he sticks to this story because bbc
lets him thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe makes me very happy
indeed
peace